let's just come out and say it that
us having this conversation
is [ __ ] explosive
like almost radioactive some people i
mean like that the interest in
people hearing from you
people hearing seeing us together is off
the charts
i did a year of alcohol treatment and i
actually have never felt better i
actually didn't realize i had such a
problem that i did
and uh dude or do that's a distinction
that we need to be clear about yeah i
guess do uh yeah
because novak said dude if you just do a
year you'll understand how much better
you will feel because you always go 30
to 60 days maybe 90 tops but if you just
do a year you'll understand and i call
them up after you i'm like novak i
understand i get it i feel great now you
know i i do not want that lifestyle i
got a four-year-old i don't miss the
hangovers whatsoever and uh i just don't
want to return to that anymore
okay and i think that that is
is very good
um i also
i have to be honest that i'm concerned
that uh
i get the impression that you feel like
all right i'm done you know i did my
year of treatment and now i'm done and
now i can kind of get back to running
around and doing my own thing like i
worry like crazy that you feel that the
problem you have with alcoholism is
something that you can handle on your
own
well i still have 90 more days of class
but i'm going to transfer to carlsbad to
finish the classes but they they still
drug test alcohol tests do every time i
go right i mean just to give you um
an idea of what it was like for me
i remember
understanding the
statistics for alcoholics staying sober
they are not in our favor bam most
alcoholics die drunk of causes related
directly to alcoholism and i i've heard
that only like five percent make it and
when i went into rehab i was like dude i
want to be in that five percent and i'm
willing to do whatever it takes to give
myself the advantage and that's why i
lived in the little halfway house to
protect my sobriety i stayed in the
little halfway house until i was two
years sober and only then when i left
the halfway house
even then i i needed to live like next
door to like a sober guy because i
wanted to protect my sobriety so much
you know like
and uh yeah
it's just important to really really
protect it and i say that as a guy who
loves you man like uh
you gotta know yeah
you know it's not my job to say who's an
alcoholic or who's not but i think that
we can agree
oh yeah yeah i know dude i've been i've
been going for it for 10 years or more
uh like
there would be breaks and [ __ ] but i
mean
there were times i would just wake up to
whiskey and hot
sure
and
all day long when i wake up with a
hangover you know
sure and every time there was a break
without fail whenever you took so much
as one sip of alcohol
then the whole gorilla came out of the
cage you open that door one little crack
and the whole gorilla comes out of the
cage and you can't get the gorilla back
in the cage yeah and not to mention if i
ever made skating plans or workout plans
i'm like dude all bets are off i'm
drinking like for some reason when i'm
drinking all activities are off i just
like to sit at home or whatever crack
jokes watch tv whatever but i mean i'll
paint and stuff but i'm i'm not
productive like skating wise or working
out wise i just don't feel like it right
and what was so hard was it hard to
admit that you had a problem or was
there so because um
man because i i
i wasn't like going out and being a uh i
wasn't going out to bars and i wasn't
being a mess
so um
the fact that i learned how to control
behaving myself but still being wasted i
felt like i i had an excuse
to say i'm
better
than i was can you help enlighten us as
to what period you're referring to when
you were able to control
being
yeah i mean dude those days are so long
gone bam like you didn't control [ __ ]
well i i've tried every which method i'm
like all right i'm only gonna sip on
weight calls from now on yeah then i'd
be like all right i'm only gonna sip
whiskey just very
every so once in a while that didn't
work out all right i'm just going to do
white wine during dinner you know that
didn't work
i've tried it all and i i figured out
that it just always turns into one glass
turns into two then it turns into a
bottle turns into two bottles that i'm
out looking for booger sugar sure
i mean
and i think that we've we've established
that over and over again and the other
thing too
is that
by definition an alcoholic can't keep
himself sober you know that's why we
have this community
of people who
keep each other sober and we stay sober
by helping other people stay sober and
i'm telling you man that like
the the secret to success
as an alcoholic is to join
this team and do what we do well that's
why i like when i packed up everything
and i moved to san marcos in southern
california because i had such a tight
group of skater friends that were sober
i navid the shaman who i was hiking with
all the time eight miles a day sometimes
five at five in the morning it was like
a ritual and then i was doing the
sheckler meetings all the time i was
doing your wednesday meeting um your
home group
and um
it was just working out then i twisted
my ankle at tony hawk's house then from
all there it was just downhill i'm
getting my six-pack of [ __ ] white
claw then then it turned into 12-pack
and then i just started sitting around
and drinking and i'm particularly
nervous
like right now and this is the reason
why i wanted to talk to you right now is
because you've got like a whole year
that you've been in treatment you're
really like a good sort of distance from
your last drink and i feel like if that
if the idea crawls into your head that
you can get away with having a sip on
some kind of a drink and then the whole
gorilla comes out of the cage again like
i really i don't want to do that anymore
yeah i feel like it's really scary after
everything you've been through over the
last year or two years that if you drink
again and and the whole gorilla comes
out then we've got a serious problem on
our hands yeah and plus i've done a year
without a phone i haven't had internet
privileges i haven't had music privilege
because all the music's on my phone so
like
once i turn my phone on and everybody
knows i did a year sober i have all
these business opportunities that i do
not want to [ __ ] up it's kind of like
when novak
got the opportunity to work for banyan
treatment center and he got a really big
paycheck that he's like oh my god you
know like he knows that if he sips on
even a glass of wine and banyan finds
out he's [ __ ] forever so like he does
not want to ruin his relationship with
banyan he's making great money and he's
helping people right you know good and
and like
with this now i have a brand new phone
number so i le when viva la bam days and
just my drunken days i let so many
people in my bubble that it just [ __ ]
exploded so many drinking bubby buddies
so many
people just yo let me get your number
like if i had a good time with you that
night he'll let me get a number yeah
sure whatever and everybody would blow
me up on the phone that i didn't even
know who was important and who to answer
to anymore now i got a tight group of
friends that i talk to on the daily you
know i don't if somebody says can i get
your number i say nope you know i i just
keep it real tight talk to danny way on
the regular yellow off on the regular
you um you know the derns novak um
kat von d you know
i love that it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude